[Music]
so what the [ __ ] is up with taxes and
why is it so [ __ ] hard to do my taxes
just finish my taxes yesterday it should
not to be that hard to do tax wait how
long did it take I mean I we have a tax
guy but like and you work the guy why do
you need a tax guy of Texas exactly it
should be easy they should just tell me
how much I owe but instead this is all
complaining corner playing quarter we
talked about the difficulties and the
real scam behind taxes there's also a
lot of conspiracy to this yeah look go
ahead let's stack that on come complete
some complaining
mmm-hmm all corners I'm right down right
there with you man it's really
complicated yes so then I have a tax
person which is also like tax tax people
when he ups out a lot be so what do you
complaint what are you complaining about
it still takes a lot of time like it
still takes a lot of time to organize
all the like the deductions that I need
to make as working as an independent
contractor because if back when I was
just working as a w-2 employee for days
so easy literally just gave me a number
and I was like alright cool and then
easy but they take more money for also
the company the the company that I
worked for paid half of that tax because
they're they're paying they're paying
into like the Medicaid and all that
other stuff that I otherwise have to
cover on my own hmm so that always like
easier and honestly you know it's less
things I have to worry about towards the
end of the year but now that I'm working
as independent contractor we're just
calling a lot of ways which one do you
like more where the there's you have
more control you could deduct more but
it's more of a pain in the ass tax wise
w2 [ __ ] yeah of course you'd rather do
w-2 but yeah do any of the duck as many
it depends on how much I'm making like
it really depends on how much I can
contract worked you're like right now
most of my stuff is contract work so I'm
and I make most of my money through
contract work so I have to say contract
work but it's also cuz I'm making a lot
more if I was making a lot more through
w2 stuff and I wasn't burdened with the
idea that I had to deduct all these
things just to you know break down that
35% tax rate that otherwise happen yeah
WT is like way easier because that's all
I'm saying our buddies he one of our
buddy was a cop he makes like 140 a year
but he's since he's a w-2 he takes home
sixty
yeah get this dog
my friend's dad he's a w-2 get Mel
single Mel homeowner not marry sorry
tell him to marry a hookers I'm sorry
desperate he wants to marry him you
think that's bad though my friends buddy
his dad right
he gets taxed he's on a w-2 he gets
taxed a million dollars
how much do it mix - yeah he makes two
but he's pissed because he came to
America with nothing in his pocket and
he was making like $200 a month and he
worked his way up in this company but
because he's a w-2 they take a million
dollars and he's like how dare he make
two million dollars so how does a
company like Amazon not pay taxes like
what do they do that's corporate tax so
the way that tank is which needs very
different kind of a myth but it's okay
yeah yeah so here's the thing if you own
the company you can pay yourself a
dollar in a year right
but everything that you kind of go
through is through the tax the the
corporate taxes I mean it's so
complicated I don't even know that
depends on what kind of entity they're
registered as to my company is so paying
taxes but the idea is that Jeff Bezos
doesn't pay taxes yet so so so I only
say it's kind of a myth as far as when
it comes to Amazon not paying taxes
that's not true buddy tax Jeff Bezos not
paying taxes is relatively true does
that make sense yeah that makes it cuz
he's a separate individual from several
individual most of his is quote unquote
billions are tied up into a sin yeah so
not liquid yeah no I thought it was the
opposite where the corporation doesn't
pay taxes but Jeff Bezos does know Jeff
because there's a whole thing right now
with Google and all these top massive
global corporations and they don't pay
any tax yes because they have but what
they do pay or really expensive
accountants they're trying to like I
mean that that's when you have that much
money you can hire really expensive
people to figure out you know who do we
donate money to so we do that we get tax
breaks we don't we you know give you
know what do we invest in where do we
you know so that we don't so they're
paying money cuz those those companies
might not even be registered in the
states they might be registered in
different country with just to clarify
when I say kind of a myth all I mean is
they do technically pay taxes it's just
not what they should be to paying a tax
Yeah right right so that's the [ __ ]
and that's where it gets confusing
because I think most people are on w-2s
so that's what they understand of taxes
right but there's also you get taxed
different if you're an investor and
you're collecting money through that way
or if you have real estate or if you own
a business or you know people who have
businesses that are valued very high but
they don't actually make any money like
a lot of these software tech guys like
you know how's that possible Joe right
so for example app developers right they
could get an app with a ton of [ __ ]
users that don't even sell any ads and
it's valued at millions of [ __ ]
dollars right but what these guys do is
they'll get something called a line of
credit from banks they'll be like you're
good for it cuz you're valued at
millions of dollars like let's say
snapchat or what I've known built Amazon
that exactly yeah they didn't make money
for almost 10 years most bizarre period
yeah make money for like the first two
years right yeah but then that's that's
that's the whole thing right as people
don't get it is like you might be you
might have an app company that's valued
at millions of dollars and you're like
oh this guy's so [ __ ] rich what this
idiot might do is they go I know I'm
gonna sell it there's prospective buyers
I'll go to the bank I'll get a line of
credit then I buy my yacht then I buy my
things but they're technically broke
because they're you spending on borrowed
money and they don't pay taxes because
they're spending on borrowed money not
income right and at the end of the day -
the government doesn't necessarily want
to tax these companies out of existence
before they can thrive and taxing is
okay the whole idea of taxes though it's
so [ __ ] important and my question is
why isn't that really taught in school
because to be a good citizen in any
country you have to understand the most
important things that make the country
work in taxes is one of them because it
collects money from the citizens we need
to know words use or whatever whatever
but it's not even taught really unless
you go take an accounting degree or
something like
class in high school or any business
class oh yeah yeah there's none of that
it was it was an elective for me in in
high school so wasn't a mandatory went
to high school in Canada right no here
okay this is classic what I call my
everyone calls they call it crony
capitalism because Jeff Bezos is allowed
to say well I make you know Han dollars
from Amazon a year or whatever he says
right and then they only tax him on that
right so while he expenses his account
like to Amazon on everything else he
doesn't get taxed for that [ __ ] yeah so
then technically it's true that you know
Amazon Amazon pays tax is just not very
much taxes right so that's where it
becomes murky and [ __ ] right so you
at you're setting up the the corporate
tax system to benefit these huge
corporations and that's where people
like me who I am personally a capitalist
but crony capitalist [ __ ] no like these
companies who are who are using offshore
accounts to get rid of like their tax
float and [ __ ] I'm against them getting
benefits and all the all these these
abilities that they have to move their
monies around what if they're on their
argument they're like we are just able
to seek out the laws and to find
loopholes within these laws and if the
laws if this is like the way the game is
set up this is how I'm gonna play the
game cool man so I'm also against the
[ __ ] is that term where if you are the
one person in the marketplace monopoly
monopoly I'm against monopolies - so
what you're talking about is something
that benefits only the super super rich
companies and [ __ ] over the smaller
companies who have to play by the rules
who can't afford these attorneys who
can't do all these loopholes yes I'm all
for competition because in capitalism
the concept is supposed to be the
marketplace that's determined but then
when you work in in collusion with
government then it's not quite true
capitalism anymore auger it's an
oligarchy because you guys you know what
we're doing is we're spending and we're
cheating instead of it being a fair
playing field now you have politicians
in your pocket and then they're writing
laws to help you out and it's the same
thing with old-school capitalism and the
reason why we have like a bad name for
for corporations and whatever is because
there's guys
they're that like oil companies or
whatever they're like hey here's some
hush money don't talk about the oil
spill whatever whatever but that's not
what capitalism is what about people
playing the game with existing laws and
not really love the show that's all the
doing is using existing laws it's just
about who can afford to use the kind of
language that they they can get aware of
that you never burn enough money and
legal fees to get it out of it is the
rule of deeper pockets I mean it's like
forever the like tightrope that we're
walking though because it's like on the
one hand we don't want to stifle like
businesses that are like smaller on the
other hand we don't want to like give
the like unreasonable power to like the
super you know huge corporation my life
would not be as awesome if because
Amazon could make one in its first
couple years they were out of business
neither would yours neither right so
it's a good thing that they weren't
taxed out of existence I like that but
on the other hand I don't like that they
have almost an invincibility zatara's
now like almost invincible now they
should yeah once you pass a certain
point of trillions of income or billions
or whatever then you get you become your
own empire within America yeah and I
even think that there when you become
that monopoly I think that we should
break up monopolies again what the [ __ ]
happened to that right like those are
cuz that's not they're playing the rules
in there like screwing over technically
we don't own this company but I mean
they're basically work with us
basically Obama and Trump that couldn't
be more diametrically opposed when you
look at the party system well guess what
none of them have broken up any
monopolies that's the point right
is that for some reason our system has
been co-opted so much that both sides
agree on [ __ ] like let's not break up
monopolies what is considered a monopoly
in today's age because I think Pacific
Bell was one well now it's a it's it's
it's a Google or alphabet solutely
Google Twitter some of the new utility
companies yeah
YouTube's under Google but point being
is it it's still it's still considered a
monopoly I think when you look at the
digital video space so Vimy open who
goes to that no but not for the same
not even close movie companies who send
private links to people to do scoring
and to do graphic animation that's all
they use it for its private links mmm
it's wild they pass them protected like
nobody uses a [ __ ] like as far as
hosting right yeah
pornhub zone monopoly - yeah [ __ ] you
they should break up pornhub well no
what about X videos what is going huh
bone I think I think monopoly don't
friend finder I yeah they should be
broken up Steve is like I they've taken
too much of my goddamn way I'm trying to
jerk off on camera yeah to decent people
what a hard working Americans to the
golden days of jerking off on cam I'm
not trying to jerk off to no algorithm
guy that's telling me two thousand
people's watching me true the porn sites
with the algorithm really [ __ ] some [ __ ]
up man because I want variety I I
smelled a jerk-off - twenty three people
and I knew that 20 people were there now
it says your two thousand three other
people were there yeah right yeah but
they're not saying much to me Bart the
comments are he has more but love less
quality he wants an emptier small
connector comments are much different
now yeah there's management axis can get
really [ __ ] crazy if you're trying to
file as an adult entertainer
ya know what the [ __ ] does this have to
do with taxes
[Music]
[Music]